[Music]
how does one distinguish a statement
coming from oneself rather than from
ideology hey I got a good hint about
that if you're saying something that
almost anyone else could say then it's
likely to be either cliched or
ideological where is if you're speaking
from yourself then in some sense you're
the only person who could be saying that
and so what that means in some sense is
that you've taken ideas philosophical
even ideological and you've made them
personal so that you're speaking from a
position that only you can speak from
and then then you have something
original to offer in Solzhenitsyn school
like archipelago he talked about like
radical communists who were thrown into
the gulag and they used to play comrade
with him it was a game and what they
would do is bait them into making
continual propagandistic communist
statements was an attempt to try to
educate them out of their possession but
it's a good see if you can predict what
someone is going to say on the basis of
their set of beliefs then they're not
speaking the ideology is speaking and if
the ideology is speaking you don't even
have to listen to them you could just
read about the ideology and make up your
own mind now so that's that's sort of
the what would you call it that's the
objective view of this the subjective
view is that statements come from
yourself that come from yourself I think
first of all frightened you to some
degree because you actually open
yourself up to the world by saying
something genuine but they also make you
stronger they make you feel stronger but
because I think you're confronting your
vulnerability properly you know because
if I tell you something that I really
don't believe and you criticize it's
like who cares because I don't really
believe it anyways so maybe I have an
ideology that's like a mask or a persona
which is generally the case and persona
is a Jungian concept that means mask and
it's often the thing that people confuse
with the real identity well if I have a
persona and someone criticizes it it's
like well you haven't gone to the real
me but if I say something that I really
believe deeply believed and then it gets
kritis
it's like I've really put myself on the
line and so people don't do that it's
kind of frightening but it's it's still
the way to genuine strength because you
need and also not just strength but also
value you need to manifest yourself in
the world because you're a unique thing
and people might need what's unique
about you everybody else might really
need that I believe that you know
because each person has something that's
unique to them to bring into being and
if they hide that they hide their light
under a bushel that everyone is poorer
for it and you do that in part as
Solzhenitsyn says by turning in you're
turning over your god-given soul to
human dogma it's a very bad idea very
bad idea